"NUMB WITH SORROW.
"ROY WAS GONE,
AND I WOULD HAVE TO LIVE MY LIFE
WITHOUT HIM."
- BEHIND ME IS DIANE MASSEY,
ONE-TIME TRAFFIC REPORTER
FOR K.L.O.W.'S LOCAL NEWS.
SOME PEOPLE
CONSIDER HER TO BE
THE ASHLEY TISDALE
OF TRAFFIC REPORTING.
SHE HAS WRITTEN A MEMOIR
ABOUT COPING WITH THE DEATH
OF HER HUSBAND, ROY.
HE DIED IN A TRAFFIC ACCIDENT,
IRONICALLY ENOUGH.
ISN'T THAT SOMETHING?
[light applause]
THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR WRITING THIS.
- OF COURSE.
- RECENTLY, UH...
I RECENTLY LOST MY WIFE.
DIANE WAS A SWEET, SAD WOMAN
IN A HIGHLY VULNERABLE STATE.
I GOT TO HAND IT TO LUCILLE.
SHE CALLED IT.
AND DIANE'S NEED FOR LOVING CARE
MADE MY TASK ALL TOO EASY.
- IS THERE SOMETHING ELSE
I CAN DO FOR YOU?
- AS A MATTER OF FACT,
THERE IS.
- OKAY.
OH.
YEAH, OH. OH, GOD.
- MM-HMM.
THE GLAMOUR OF SLEEPING WITH
A FAMOUS WOMAN WAS UNDENIABLE.
BUT ULTIMATELY,
WE WERE JUST PEOPLE,
AND OUR SEXUAL ENCOUNTER WOULD
END THE WAY THEY USUALLY DO.
- OH, NO!
[crying]
OH, ROY!
OH.
BRING ME ROY.
- I DON'T KNOW WHAT--I'M SORRY.
I DON'T KNOW HOW TO DO THAT.
- GIVE ME RO--
BRING ME HIS ASHES.
BRING ME ROY.
[sobbing]
- ALL RIGHT.
- BRING ME HIS ASHES.
OH, MY ROY.
[sobbing]
- I'LL PROBABLY, UH--
PROBABLY GET GOING THERE.
- YOU CAN CALL ME IF YOU WANT.
- OKAY.